un nouvel attentat à paris il ya au
moins cinq morts et 50 blessés dont onze
sont gravement touchés la bombe a été
semble-t-il lancée d'une voiture contre
le grand magasin populaire tati dans le
quartier de montparnasse pour le moment
face de revendications les frères de
georges ibrahim abdallah actuellement
recherché par la police sont au liban
ils ont tenu tout à l'heure une
conférence de presse devant des
journalistes libanais ils affirment
qu'ils ne sont pour rien dans les
attentats et qui sont prêts à se livrer
aux autorités ce mercredi 17 septembre
86 cela fait 5 144 jours de détention
pour marcel carton et pour marcel
fontaine 483 jours de détention pour
jean paul kauffmann et pour michel
seurat 193 jours pour aurel cornéa et
pour jean louis normandin antenne 2 et
133 jours pour camille sontag
il y a toujours sept otages français
détenus au liban
bonsoir encore un attentat en plein
paris avec un bilan très lourd au moins
cinq morts onze blessés graves et 50
blessés plus légers pas de revendication
je vous le disais pas de revendication
en tout cas pour le moment une bombe qui
a semble-t-il été lancée d'une voiture
contre la devanture du magasin tati à
montparnasse était aux environs de 17h30
l'heure de sortie des bureaux
il y avait donc beaucoup de monde dans
la rue tout de suite les précisions en
direct avec les équipes de reportage qui
se sont immédiatement rendus sur les
lieux
quelques minutes seulement après
l'explosion des images exceptionnelles
filmé par une équipe de la télévision
coréenne les dizaines de victimes
allongées ensanglanté certaines ont dû
être évacués par hélicoptère les témoins
hagard un véritable climat d'affolement
dans ce quartier commerçant les
terroristes ont frappé peu avant 17h30 à
une heure où les magasins sont
particulièrement fréquenté la cible des
terroristes
tati fréquenté par une pile en clientèle
populaire et ce mercredi surtout des
femmes et des enfants
ce soir le quartier montparnasse était
entièrement bouclé par la police
le wac de mots horreur écoeurement alors
en direct avec nous bruno le dreff qui
est sur place bruno et quels sont les
premiers éléments de l'enquète tout à
l'heure écoutez ce que je peux vous dire
d'abord c'est que deux heures et demie
après l'attentât les derniers blessés
viennent seulement d'être évacués dont
certains par hélicoptère c'est vous dire
l'ampleur des dégâts l'ampleur de
l'explosion
alors maintenant sur place ce sont les
enquêteurs les hommes du laboratoire de
la préfecture de police de paris qui
essayent de rechercher de retrouver des
traces pour remonter éventuellement une
filière à partir de l'explosif qui a été
utilisé nous disposons pour l'instant de
deux informations qui sont quelque peu
contradictoires tout d'abord d'après un
médecin qui habite sur place et un
policier la bombe se trouvait dans une
poubelle qui se trouve juste à
l'extérieur en face du magasin
mais ensuite le procureur davenas ce
nous a annoncé que d'après ses
informations qui semblent plus sûres
la bombe aurait été lancée par deux
hommes moustachu qui se trouvait à bord
d'une bmw noire qui évidemment repartis
très rapidement alors immédiatement la
police a mis en place des barrages dans
la capitale pour l'instant ils sont
toujours sans résultat et puis on vient
juste de m'apporter une dernière
information
un homme aurait été arrêté aux galeries
lafayette il y à quelques instants il
portait sur lui à un manuel du haj des
explosifs
mais il ya encore peu d'explications
plus peu de précisions quant à cette
arrestation
vous ne vous restait sur place vous
retrouvera tout à fait à la fin de ce
journal pour d'autres informations
d'autres précisions peut être déjà des
témoignages ouest et donc à l'autre bout
de ce fil pour nous tenir informés de ce
qui se passe en ce moment donc à
montparnasse j'ajoute que monsieur
chirac à convoquer immédiatement un
conseil de sécurité c'est-à-dire un
conseil qui comprend les ministres de
l'intérieur de la justice de la sécurité
des affaires étrangères et de la défense
donc pour pour parler de ce problème de
cet avantage aujourd'hui peut-être
d'ailleurs une intervention tout à
l'heure en direct dans ce journal de
monsieur chirac sur place comme olivier
werner qui est bien sûr en éveil
l'actualité sur le terrorisme c'est
aussi un coup de théâtre les deux hommes
les plus recherchés de france qui
apparaissent au liban et de frère de
georges ibrahim abdallah qui font
l'objet d'un appel à témoins ont tenu
tout à l'heure une conférence de presse
à tripoli au nord de beyrouth
ils démentent toute participation aux
attentats et propose de se livrer aux
autorités françaises s'ils sont inculpés
c'est donc un véritable coup de thé
même s'il faut demeurer extrêmement
prudent devant leurs affirmations qu'ils
sont quand même pour le moment que des
mots sur cette étrange conférence de
presse tenue dans les bureaux de
l'agencé d'informations américaine
associée de presse voici le commentaire
de bruno alpes il n'y a qu'un document
image de la conférence de presse donnée
cet après midi à tripoli par les deux
frères d'ibrahim abdallah cette photo
les deux hommes seraient arrivés de leur
village de courbet l'hyatt pour se
contacter improvisé avec les
journalistes leur identité ne semble pas
faire de doute
à gauche robert ibrahim abdallah
le plus jeune à droite maurice recherché
par la police française depuis 18 mois
ils n'ont apparemment pas répondu à des
questions et se sont limités à lire un
communiqué il affirmait avoir quitté la
france depuis 1984 et n'être pour rien
dans les récents attentats de paris
ils ont même proposé de se livrer à la
police française
la date de cette photo ne fait pas de
doute
le journal al safir disposé devant les
deux hommes reproduit leurs photos tel
que diffusé depuis hier par la police en
france
robert et maurice ibrahim abdallah sont
depuis hier les deux hommes les plus
recherchés de france la police je
voulais dit a lancé contre eux un appel
à témoins avec une récompense d'un
million de francs pensant probablement
qu'ils étaient encore en france et
aujourd'hui on ne parlait même plus de
témoins mais deux suspects puisque l'un
des deux frères étaient précisément
soupçonné d'avoir posé la bombe dans la
cafétéria de la défense
comment la police mais est elle arrivée
à cette conclusion c'est ce que nous
explique maintenant thierry calme est un
témoin jugé très crédible par les
policiers eux mêmes
vendredi ils déjeunaient ici à la
défense à côté du poseur de bombe
présumé
il a décrit le comportement de celui ci
il en a donné un signalement précis qui
a permis de dresser un portrait robot
un portrait robot qui ressemblerait
trait pour trait à robert ibrahim
abdallah reconnu aussi sur ce portrait
robot par une des personnes interpellées
récemment à paris robert et maurice
ibrahim abdallah sont les deux plus
jeunes frères de georges abdallah est
membre eux aussi des farl originaire
d'un village du liban
la police judiciaire a reconstitué leur
trajet en décembre 83
il s'inscrit à la faculté catholique
lyon février 84 espagne en août genève
puis de fréquents séjours en belgique la
même année en mars avril et août en
novembre 84 les deux frères saison en
allemagne fédérale
puis la trace se perd on entendra parler
d'eux au mois d'avril 85 au liban ils
viennent de libérer sydney pérol enlever
un mois auparavant
à ce moment-là signer pérol devait
peut-être être échangé contre le frère
aîné de la famille georges chef présumé
des farl arrêté à lyon
mais voilà celui ci se trouve toujours
en prison en france et les attentats
continuent
l'apparition des deux frères aujourd'hui
au liban pose un problème aux policiers
robert ibrahim pouvait-il être à la
cafétéria de la défense vendredi les
deux cent mille affiches avec leurs
photos qui devait être apposée dans les
lieux publics sont elle opportune une
démarche exceptionnelle avec une prime
de 1 million de francs à la clé la
mémoire des témoins va être mise à rude
épreuve au cours de son enquête et
probablement à la suite de l'appel à
témoins d'hier la police a découvert
aujourd'hui quelque part en région
parisienne n'a pas plus de précisions un
véritable arsenal composé d'explosifs de
grenades et de détonateurs une très
grosse prise qui permettra peut-être de
faire avancer les recherches
patrice pollet comment ces images qui
ont été tournées je le précise par les
soins du ministère de l'intérieur la
police ne veut pas dire ce soir où elle
a découvert cet arsenal
seule précision très vague c'est bien
dans la région parisienne que cette
planque a été découverte
40 kg d'explosifs des grenades plus de
80 détonateur et un rouleau de cordons
détonants
c'est sur dénonciation suite à l'appel à
témoins lancé hier par la police que
cette cache a été découverte sur
l'origine et l'utilisation éventuelle
des explosifs et des armes
pas de révélation et le ministère de
l'intérieur de préciser qu'aucun détail
en l'état actuel de l'enquêté ne peut
être donnée avait promis un nouvel
attentat des informations mais surtout
toujours autant de questions et comment
ne pas se poser des questions lorsque
l'on confronte ces deux faits d'un côté
un nouvel attentat meurtrier à paris de
l'autre la présence au liban des deux
principaux suspects des deux frères de
georges ibrahim abdallah maurice et
robert cuesmes moment vienne tout simple
mantoue tranquillement se disculper lors
d'une conférence de presse s'il vous
plaît en dix ans nous n'y sommes pour
rien pour les services spécialisés cela
pourrait bien n'être qu'une mise en
scène fait nouveau dans sa cellule
georges ibrahim abdallah commence à
parler
il aurait confié que son groupe les
fractions armées révolutionnaires
libanaises dont il est le chef sont
manipulés par un état sans d'ailleurs
préciser lequel
les phares la jce certes dit-il mais
contrainte les enquêteurs n'accorde que
peu de fois ce beau discours
il se borne à constater qu une
dissension est peut-être en train de
naître au sein des phares certains
souhaiteraient marquer une pause dans la
vague de violences
d'autres n'auraient qu'un seul objectif
faire toujours plus monter la pression
et c'est bien ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui rue de rennes 17h20
françois mitterrand a bien sûr été
immédiatement informées de l'attentât de
mots par l'as le chef de l'état qui
était en indonésie vous savez pour une
visite officielle il ya même eu tout à
l'heure à très longue coup de téléphone
entre le premier ministre monsieur
chirac et le président de la république
ils ont tous les deux fait le point de
la situation
donc après l'attentât de la rue de
rennes messieurs chirac je vous rappelle
président en ce moment-même donc à
matignon un conseil de sécurité
intérieure monsieur mitterrand qui est
donc en indonésie et ce matin il avait
avant même de connaître cet attentat il
avait réaffirmé qu'il fallait combattre
le terrorisme sans merci
la règle de tout pays civilisé la règle
en tout cas du tout démocratie menacés
agressés par le terrorisme l'apd le plus
le plus vil de règles de l absolu qui
veulent respirer toute action la
première c'est que le terrorisme doit
être combattue sans merci permettez moi
de me répéter la deuxième mais ce qui se
passe sur le même plan
c'est que les règles de la pratique
démocratique doivent être respectées si
le dixième règle n'est pas observée ce
serait déjà une victoire du terrorisme
mais vous pouvez faire confiance
de même vous êtes français dans le sens
de la tradition convictions personnelles
et dans le souci pour le dirigeant de
de préserver ce qui fait la grandeur de
notre peuple
d'abord visera donc lutter contre le
terrorisme mais aussi vivre selon les
lois qu'on s'est fixés le respect de la
démocratie puis en réponse à une
question le président évoque les mesures
prises par jacques chirac
quand on est dans une période où il faut
serrer les dents ou il faut un surface à
une multitude de péril on peut admettre
que des mesures restrictives dérogatoire
est provisoire soit prise
est ce que c'est la réponse à tous cette
mesure bien entendu personne ne nous en
faisons pas d'illusions nous savons bien
qu'il ya bien des gens qui qui viennent
en france sans demander la permission
nous savons aussi qu'il y a des relais
en france mais c'est une mesure c'est
une arme dans une panoplie on déclare ce
qui peut paraître un peu décalé dans le
temps je vous rappelle qu'elle était
faite avant donc l'attentât de cet
après-midi dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme toutes les bonnes volontés
sont bienvenues vous l'imaginez avec
l'initiative de plusieurs intellectuels
arabes vivant en france mais aussi de
jeunes beurs qui sont allés ce matin à
la prison de fleury mérogis but de leur
démarche remettre une lettre ouverte
demandant à georges ibrahim abdallah
détenus dans cette prison de faire
cesser ce qu'ils appellent les attentats
massacre reportage patrice pollet et
patrick des français musulmans des beurs
des immigrés environ cinquante
signatures pour une lettre ouverte à
georges ibrahim abdallah détenu à fleury
mérogis une lettre remise ce matin aux
terroristes par l'intermédiaire du
directeur de la prison
un texte qui demandent à georges ibrahim
abdallah d'intervenir pour que cessent
les attentats terroristes
quelle que soit la justesse de votre
combat vous n'avez pas le droit et
n'aurait jamais notre assentiment pour
semer la terreur et reprendra la mort le
conflit d'humour moyen-orient ne peut se
régler sur les berges de la seine les
signataires de cette lettre craignent
d'autre part que les mesures de sécurité
ne se retourne contre les immigrés et
les français musulmans
il ya une sorte de psychose et quand il
ya des tas de psychose comme ça c'est
dangereux et douloureux on voudrait leur
dire qu'il ya aussi des basanés qui sont
corrects qui sont français et qui n'ont
rien à voir avec le terrorisme
une démarche avant tout symbolique
georges ibrahim abdallah aura s'il le
souhaite le droit d'y répondre par écrit
voilà donc ce que l'on pourrait dire au
soir de cet attentat cet attentat de la
rue de rennes chez tactique donc fait
cinq morts onze blessés graves et 50
blessés plus légers un attentat qui n'a
toujours pas été revendiqué il nous faut
aussi parler du reste de l'actualité en
france et dans le monde avec notamment
une catastrophe minière très importante
en afrique du sud
cent soixante dix mineurs sont morts et
des dizaines d'autres sont disparues un
drame qui s'est produit dans une mine
d'or près de johannesburg commentaires
jules cette catastrophe s'est produite à
la mine d'or de kinross une des plus
importantes mines d'afrique du sud
c'est une bouteille de gaz servant à
faire des travaux de soudure qui a
explosé provocante immédiatement un
incendie à 1620 mètres de profondeur
plus d'un kilomètre et demi sous terre
alors que près de 2500 mineurs
travaillaient au fond il a fallu huit
heures aux équipes de secours pour
maîtriser le sinistre
presque toutes les victimes sont mortes
asphyxiées par d'épaisses fumées
toxiques qui ont envahi les pluies mais
la grande majorité des ouvriers ont
réussi à échapper à la mort en se
réfugiant dans quelques poches d'air de
certaines galeries attendant plus de
quatre heures les secours
235 blessés ont été hospitalisés dans
les hôpitaux de la région
la communauté noire est la plus touchée
par cette catastrophe
la plupart des mineurs sont des
travailleurs immigrés venus de pays
voisins
l'actualité c'est aussi la visite de
françois mitterrand en indonésie le chef
de l'état qui demeure bien sûr informés
de ce qui se passe en ce moment en
france
pourtant aujourd'hui ce qu'on retiendra
de cette visite sur place c'est une
manifestation contre le régime du
général suharto
à l'occasion de la présence de monsieur
mitterrand le reportage de dominique
laurie et de jacques aubertin qui sont
autorisés françois mitterrand
indirectement aura permis l'expression
l'indonésie d'une certaine contestation
étudiante non violemment réprimées ce
n'est pas fréquent dans ce pays la
dernière manifestation d'étudiants
remonte à 79 les élèves de l'institut de
technologie de bandung ont profité ce
matin de la visite du président pour
réclamer plus de liberté sur le campus
et dans le pays
commentaire non sans humour de françois
mitterrand devant les enseignants
rassemblez vos étudiants sont riches
d'énergie et de vitalité
et comme les nouvelles vont vite à sa
sortie il a reçu un excellent accueil
raidissement spectaculaire des
etats-unis à l'encontre de moscou le
gouvernement américain vient en effet
d'exiger le départ de 25 diplomate
appartenant diplomates soviétiques
appartenant donc à la mission soviétique
auprès des nations unies c'est un degré
nouveau de l'escaladé entre les deux
pays à propos sans doute georges bortoli
de la sphère danilov journalistes
américains qui avaient été arrêtés et
condamnés par dont l'accusé d'espionnage
à moscou oui on l'avait un peu oublié
mais le 7 mars dernier les états unis
avaient déjà demandé la réduction de
plus d'un tiers de la mission soviétique
aux nations unies motif invoqué par les
américains il y a trop de monde 275
personnes et parmi elles il y aurait
trop d'espions le gouvernement
soviétique tardé à répondre à la
washington force la lure en exigeant
tout de suite dit si 1er octobre le
départ dans un premier temps de 25
diplomates soviétiques à l'onu c'est
donc un coup de poing sur la table à un
moment particulièrement choisi puisque
le ministre soviétique chercher vers
nice et doit rencontrer son homologue
américain schulz
après demain or monsieur chose veut
absolument vous l'avez dit obtenir la
liberté totale du journaliste américain
danny love qui ne peut toujours pas
quitté moscou et c'est pour cela en
dépit des démentis officiels c'est pour
cela que washington augmente la pression
à un endroit très sensible car moscou
tient beaucoup vous le savez à sa
présentation aux nations unies la
famille kennedy toujours éprise de
politique avec l'arrivée en lice de ce
que l'on appelle la troisième génération
joseph kennedy le fils de bob kennedy
assassiné vient d'être désigné comme
candidat démocrate au siège de député du
massachusetts
une affaire de famille puisque sa soeur
a fait de même mais dans le maryland
commentaire jacquat bouchard à
washington joe 33 ans je veux blanc
bouclé le dernier produit de l'écurie
kennedy lancer dans le grand bain
électorale hier il a terrassé 10
adversaires dont le petit fils de
l'ancien président franck la route
valent pour l'investiture du parti
démocrate aux élections législatives du
4 novembre prochains jo portera les
espoirs du parti dans la circonscription
du massachussetts son oncle
fitzgerald le président assassiné avait
débuté sa brillante carrière politique
dans la bataille électorale de novembre
les couleurs du célèbre clan seront
également représentées par kathleen
soeur cadette de jo et les candidates
dont le mari landes un poste de membre
de la chambre des représentants
kathleen n'a pas la faveur des
pronostics alors que l'on prévoit une
victoire dans un fauteuil beaux jo
beaucoup la journée d'hier les dupont
ont été à l'honneur eux aussi grâce à
cet homme pierre dupont ancien
gouverneur de l'état du delta one son
nom ne dégage pas la même magie celui
des kennedy
son ambition n'en est pas moins grand
mais espère être le premier du pont à
conquérir la maison blanche
il est d'ailleurs le premier candidat à
se déclarer officiellement pour la
course à la présidence en 88
l'homme a quelques arguments à faire
valoir il appartient à la lignée célèbre
aux etats unis des dupont de nemours un
moment de détente maintenant dans ce
journal très pesant avec l un des grands
salons du moment ce salon de la musique
qui se tient actuellement à la ville est
une véritable fête de la musique et du
chant puisqu'on attend cent mille
visiteurs
on pourra y voir dix ministres eu manque
on pourra y entendre 50 concerts c'est
le reportage de jean jacques dufour et
de philippe menut
en rythme et en cadence une rapide
visite du salon de la musique le xiiie
où il y a dix mille instruments a testé
le premier sûrement le plus petit set
harmonica les façons tout de suite aux
jolies guitare et notamment à la guitare
utilisée par beaucoup de stars du
showbiz et commercialisé pour la
première fois en france comment vous la
trouvez
il faut s'habituer au doigté sinon toute
personne vraiment très bien ici sur
vingt mille mètres carrés on trouve tout
ce qui fait la musique d'aujourd'hui
côté santé voilà le dernier joujou de
luxe de chez honneur
la musique c'est un plaisir mais
également un marché économique important
le monde de la musique ça représente
environ 15000 personnes qui travaillent
à la fabrication et à la vente
d'instruments et un chiffre d'affaires à
peu près stable d'environ deux milliards
de francs république 200 milliards de
centimes pour les fanas de swing noter
la sortie de l'annuaire du rock utile
mais en tant que musicien j'ai eu moi
même souvent des problèmes à trouver les
adresses dont j'avais besoin pour
répéter etc et je me suis dit que ce
serait peut-être intéressant pour eux
d'avoir en 200 pages l'ensemble des
adresses numéros de téléphone contacts
pour jouer jouer on peut le faire
jusqu'au 21 septembre au salon de la
musique en restant les innombrables
nouveautés ou les instruments plus
classiques comme des pianos il y en a en
quantité
leur prix de 8000 francs à l'infini ou
presque maintenant si vous ne pratiquer
aucun instrument
vous pouvez assister en spectateurs aux
concerts prévus cette année
ah oui nous avons deux salles de
spectacle une salle consacrée
entièrement à la musique classique et
une salle consacrée au rock à la variété
la chanson française avec beaucoup
beaucoup d'artistes qui vont passer
aujourd'hui on pouvait admirer sa four
qui soit dit en passant sera au bataclan
à partir de ce soir et pour dix jours
les pronostics de pierrette brès
maintenant pour le quarté qui se court
demain sur l'hippodrome de maisons
laffitte il y à 21 partants et vous
suggère de jouer le 3 le 19 le 2 le 6 le
set
las le 17 et le 12 3 19 de 6,7 à ce 17
et 12 l'an trouver maintenant bruno le
dreff en direct pour des précisions donc
et de nouveaux éléments peut-être dans
l' enquête
après donc la tente à tout à l'heure rue
de rennes bruno vous écoutez je voulais
d'abord vous faire découvrir des images
je pense que nous allons les voir dans
un instant nous venons juste de les
tourner c'était le lieu de l'explosion
des images assez impressionnante on
comprend le nombre de victimes quand on
les voit
et puis ensuite voici donc quelles sont
les dernières informations dont nous
disposons il y a deux témoignages
contradictoires ou bien la bombe se
trouvait être dans une poubelle face au
magasin ou bien la bombe aurait été
lancée par deux hommes moustachu qui se
trouvait dans une bmw noire voici enfin
les toutes dernières informations que
nous avons pu recueillir ici
un homme aurait été arrêté aux galeries
lafayette montparnasse à deux pas de
l'endroit où où la bombe a explosé
il avait sur lui un manuel d'explication
d'utilisation des explosifs
et puis la brigade criminelle vient
d'arrêter dans le 6e arrondissement
toujours à paris donc un libanais qui
avait sur lui encore un manuel cette
fois ci un manuel concernant le
terrorisme
voici donc toutes les informations dont
nous disposons pour l'instant nous
n'avons peut-être les images que vous
nous parliez on les a pas encore vu
c'est vous qui nous les envoyer non
bernard vous devez les avoir sur plat
alors si la régie blé voici donc connu
les commenter voilà c'est donc ici que
la bombe a sauté
on est donc devant le 142 rue de rennes
absolument juste à l'entrée du magasin
tati
d'accord c'est la dent qui est le plus
de victimes
bien
c'est donc la toute dernière image que
vient de tourner notre équipe qui est
sur place je propose maintenant de
retrouver jean louis le scène qui
apparemment se trouve à l'hôtel matignon
avec jean-louis des précisions donc
après le conseil de sécurité que
monsieur chirac a réuni tout à l'heure
oui d'abord pour vous dire que le
conseil de sécurité qui a commencé bien
avant 19h se poursuit à l'heure actuelle
est que françois mitterrand à jakarta
est tenu informé heure par heure du
déroulement des opérations
juste avant la réunion de ce conseil de
sécurité intérieure jacques chirac et
françois mitterrand se sont d'ailleurs
longuement entretenus ensemble au
téléphone sur cette affaire je vous
rappelle qu'au tour de jacques chirac il
y a charles pasqua robert pandraud le
ministre de la justice le garde des
sceaux albin chalandon monsieur raymond
qui est à jakarta avec le premier
ministre avec le président de la
république est représentée par son
directeur de cabinet il y a le directeur
de cabinet de jacques chirac maurice
ulrich sont arrivés il y a que peu de
temps balladur monsieur balladur et
monsieur giraud monsieur toubon et
monsieur roumanie se sont joints à eux
il ya quelques instants c'est tout ce
que je peux vous dire pour l'instant
il faudra de toute façon jean louis dans
le dernier journal avec d'autres
précisions
et probablement une réaction de monsieur
chirac rajoute qu'il y a bien sûr de
nombreuses réactions ce soir après cet
attentat qui a fait donc cinq morts et
50 blessés nous livre les principales
madame veil qui estime que l'on veut
ainsi semer la panique
monsieur toubon donc qui lui fait lancé
un appel au calme il faut garder son
calme son sang froid
l'absence de panique c'est d'abord la
meilleure réponse at il dit tout à
l'heure le parti socialiste qui exprime
son émotion et son indignation
edmond maire qui souhaite une prise de
position commune des syndicats pour la
sauvegarde de la démocratie
et puis la licra qui estime que l'on
vient de déclarer la guerre à la
démocratie enfin condamnation aussi de
l'attentât par andré bergeron de force
ouvrière qui met en garde tout comme
edmond maire contre les risques de
déstabilisation de notre société
démocratique
nous verrons dans le dernier journal
mais pour l'heure et bien nous parlons
météo avec leurs rangs boussier la météo
qui sera encore une fois la page un
petit peu gay ce soir puisque pour la
première fois depuis six jours de
grisaille et de pluie bien il ya
quelques éclaircies qui reviennent le
soleil revient timidement regardez la
photo pris cet après-midi par meteosat
une photo où l'on voit un anticyclone ya
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas vu bien
grâce à lui
je fonce évacuées définitivement vers
l'est laissant leur place à de l'air
c'est vrai un petit peu plus frais mais
aussi beaucoup plus sec de l'ère où on
verra enfin le soleil regard de la carte
du temps prévu pour demain en milieu de
journée avec ao nord ouest d'une ligne
bordeaux reims en ciel dégagé qui se
dégagera dans la matinée de toute façon
un ciel dégagé avec quelques nuages
résiduels évidemment mais aussi des
éclaircies qui deviendront de plus en
plus belle dans la journée du limousin
disons du centre aux ardennes et au
nord-est le ciel restera nuageux à
couvert avec quelques ondées
enfin sur le sud du pays hôte pourtour
méditerranéen toujours des nuages
toujours quelques éclaircies toujours
quelques risques d'orages
sauf sur la corse où le temps sera beau
côté températures elles bien sont en
légère hausse et le redevienne à peu
près normale pour la saison de 13 à 16
degrés sur la moitié nord avec 14 degrés
à paris xiii c'était à cherbourg et sur
la moitié sud de 15° à tours jusqu'à 29
degrés encore une fois encore on termine
avec notre agenda comme tous les jours
demain sera le jeudi 18 7 ans le soleil
se lèvera à 7h32 se couchera 19h57 trois
minutes de soleil en moins nous fêterons
les nadège je vous rappelle avec regret
l'information l'information dramatique
de cette journée un nouvel attentat à
paris c'était devant chez tactile rue de
rennes à montparnasse
il y a cinq morts 50 blessés dont 11 qui
sont grièvement touchés
une bombe apparemment qui aurait été
lancé d'une voiture qui passait donc
devant ce magasin populaire un moment il
y avait beaucoup beaucoup de monde cinq
morts donc c'est un attentat qui n'a
pour l'instant pas été revendiquée
dernier développement dernière précision
peut être d'autres réactions dans notre
dernière édition ce sera avec bernard
pradines haut et ce sera aux environs du
23 ans
bonsoir à demain 20 heures
e